so the nutcracker it's always a holiday
favorite for all of us but unfortunately
not at the smith center this year
because of the pandemic
but there is a new exhibit it gives you
a rare look at the costumes and the set
pieces up close
hector mejia live inside the discovery
children's museum
all dressed up hey hector you look good
audrey stop thank you alex and you know
what this is actually a real piece from
the production the las vegas production
is actually
one of the most unique in the entire
country and here in las vegas we have a
chance to
come on down to the discovery children's
museum and get
really close to all of these pieces this
is a really neat thing that says
what is this here we have roy with the
nevada valley theater to explain
what we have here this is uh harlequin
here and
columbine his partner over here and
they're two dolls
that come to life in the party scene and
uh just like magic just like magic
and they do a little dance for the kids
in the party scene
and then sitting in the middle is all
this is a dancing bear and all of these
pieces
are from the production they are from
the actual show
yes and in non-pandemic years
we wouldn't have the opportunity to do
something like this but since we're
not able to perform next door at the
smith center we're really happy to have
this opportunity
with discovery people will be able to
come in and see
the actual pieces from the show this
looks
realistic this is the rat queen this is
the rat queen up here
looking down at you there she is there
she is
rat queen and then her her rat minions
here
uh they play a very important role in
the battle scene they get in a fight
they get in a fight they get in the
fight with the nutcracker over here and
there is a nutcracker
and they're kind of scary this morning
yeah he's uh he
does have a little scary well he's got
to fight he's look what he's got to
fight oh yeah she is not pretty she is
not pretty mm-hmm
so yeah this is our little this is all
from that battle scene
there's the cannon uh obviously he's got
a sword in the cannon and
i can't i can't i don't want to spoil it
i can't tell you who wins but
uh it's very exciting tell us you know
quickly
what makes the las vegas production so
unique and stand out
well i think the the first thing is just
the scope of it i mean it was built
the first year that the smith center
opened in the smith center such a
wonderful venue
and huge huge stage space so when james
canfield created this
this production in 2012 he really wanted
to use all the space so
it's it's really truly larger than life
thank you for having us sorry in the
morning and alex i'm not talented enough
to dance so i guess i'll have to settle
for being a mannequin i guess and just
standing here
hector i've seen you dance that i do not
agree with that
you are great thank you so much it's so
cool to see that stuff up close
you're welcome have fun out there